this is about the dependent samples
t-test you will easily understand how
you can calculate and interpret it
and what the requirements are so let's
get started
the t-test for dependent samples tests
whether the mean value of two dependent
samples significantly differ from each
other in the case of dependent samples
the measured values are away level in
pairs the pairs result for example by
measurement repetitions with the same
persons before you can calculate a
t-test of course you must formulate your
hypotheses in the case of the dependent
t test the null hypothesis is there is
no significant difference between the
means of the two dependent groups and
your alternative hypothesis would be
there is a significant difference
between the means of the two dependent
groups
how does the dependency test work
let's say you want to test whether a
diet program developed by a celebrity
really has an effect on people's weight
your null hypothesis is the diet program
has no significant effect on the body
weight of the participants
you measure the weight of the test
person's once before and once after the
diet program
the measured values are always in pairs
and that's why you have a dependent
sample
we are not interested in the weight
before and after but we are interested
in the difference between before and
after
on average the participants lost
0.75 kilos
what about the requirements don't we
have to check them first that is
absolutely correct however first i would
like to explain the basics to you by
using an example and then we will go
into the requirements
we want to calculate the t test but how
do we get to the t value
in order to calculate the t value
we first need the number of cases we
have four dependent pairs so we have
four cases
the number of degrees of freedom is the
number of cases minus one which makes
three
we calculate the mean of the data minus
0.7
kilos
next thing we need is the standard
deviation
for this data we get a standard
deviation of 5.84
by using the standard deviation and the
number of cases we can now calculate the
standard error of mean which is
2.84 so and now we can finally calculate
the t value the t value is the mean
minus zero divided
by the standard error of the mean
now we need to check whether the amount
of this calculated t value is smaller or
larger than the so called critical t
value
we can find the critical t value in a
table but how does this work
we have set a significance level of 5
percent
if we are testing an undirected
hypothesis this would mean that we split
the five percent between the left and
the right side
so we have 2.5 on the left and 2.5
percent on the right side
therefore in the table of critical t
values we need to look at
97.5 percent
this is what we get by subtracting half
the significance level from 1. so we are
in this column right now the degrees of
freedom in our case are 5 minus 1 which
makes 3. so we are in the table in this
row so the critical t value is 3.182
therefore the critical t value is
greater than the amount of the t value
that we have calculated if the magnitude
of the calculated t value is less than
the critical t value the null hypothesis
is maintained our calculated t value was
smaller than the critical t value
therefore based on these data we retain
the null hypothesis and assume that the
diet program has no effect on body
weight
so let's start with the first assumption
now as the name theta's for dependent
sample suggests the groups must be
dependent for example a value of one
group must belong to a value of the
other group the condition is fulfilled
for example if the weight of one and the
same person is measured before and after
a diet program assumption two is that
the variables must be metric
in the t test for the abandoned samples
the difference of the two dependent
values is calculated and then we
calculate the mean of course this only
makes sense if our values have a metric
scale level
the third assumption assumes that the
differences of the paired values are
normally distributed and now i will
explain to you how you can calculate it
online with data tab in order to do this
just google data tab click on the
statistics calculator and copy your own
data into this table
then select this tab and click on the
variables you want to analyze
data that recognizes that there are
dependent samples and automatically
calculates a t-test for dependent
samples
here you can read the p-value if the
p-value is smaller than your defined
significance level for example five
percent
then the null hypothesis is rejected
based on the available data
furthermore you can also check the
assumptions and get an interpretation in
words
the score before vacation had lower
values than the score after vacation a
dependent sample status showed that this
difference was not statistically
significant
this results in a p-value of 0.197
which is above the established
significance level of
0.05
i hope you enjoyed the video if you like
just try datadeb it's very easy to use
bye and see you next time
you